♪
>> WE WANT TO BE VERY
TRANSPARENT, SO, AS YOU
KNOW, I DECLASSIFIED
EVERYTHING.
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO SEE HOW
THIS HOAX, HOW THE HOAX OR
WITCH-HUNT STARTED AND WHY
IT STARTED.
IT WAS A -- AN ATTEMPTED
COUP OR ATTEMPTED TAKEDOWN
OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT I WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT.
EVERYBODY WANTED ME TO
DECLASSIFY.
I HAVE DONE IT.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO LEARN A
LOT.
I HOPE IT'S GOING TO BE
NICE.
BUT PERHAPS IT WON'T BE.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
HIS WAY TO JAPAN TALKING
ABOUT DECLASSIFYING
INTELLIGENCE.
ACTUALLY AUTHORIZING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
DECLASSIFY WHATEVER HE HAD
TO IN THE INVESTIGATION INTO
THE INVESTIGATORS.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN TWEETED
OUT WHILE TRUMP STONEWALLS
THE PUBLIC ABOUT LEARNING
THE TRUTH OF HIS OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE.
TRUMP AND BARR CONSPIRE TO
WEAPONIZE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
AGAINST THEIR POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
THE COVERUP HAS ENTERED A
NEW AND DANGEROUS PHASE.
THIS IS UNAMERICAN.
WITH THAT LET'S BRING IN OUR
PANEL.
STEVE HILTON IS THE HOST OF
THE NEXT REVOLUTION HERE ON
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST LESSLY
MARSHALL AND BEN SHAPIRO,
EDITOR AND CHIEF OF THE
DAILY WATER.
HERE HE IS.
BEN, WHAT DO YOU THINK.
>> I THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME
WE GOT SOME OF THE RUMORS
OUT OF THE WAY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
CLAIMING THERE HAS BEEN SOME
MASSIVE CONSPIRACY AGAINST
HIM SINCE THE BEGINNING.
THE MORE MATERIAL THE PUBLIC
EYE THE BETTER.
I FELT THAT WAY ABOUT THE
MUELLER REPORT AS WELL.
I DO HAVE SOME ISSUES WITH
ADAM SCHIFF WHO CLAIMED FOR
YEARS THAT THERE WAS SECRET
INFORMATION THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS A RUSSIAN CATS
PAW DECLARING NOW
INFORMATION IS INCREDIBLY
DANGEROUS THAT SEEMS LIKE
QUITE A FLIP FOR HIM.
>> Bret: THE COVERUP HAS
ENTERED A NEW AND DANGEROUS
PHASE.
WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE
COVERUP.
>> I'M WONDERING WHAT THE
COVERUP ACTUALLY CONSTITUTES
HERE SINCE WE ACTUALLY CAN
SEE THE MUELLER REPORT.
IN FACT, IT'S A BEST SELLER.
WE CAN ALL READ IT.
THE PORTIONS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN RELEASED INTO THE
PUBLIC ARENA HAVE NOT BEEN
DONE SO FOR BECAUSE OF
FEDERAL RULES OF CRIMINAL
EVIDENCE THAT PREVENT THAT
FROM BEING DONE.
I FAIL TO SEE WHERE THE
COVERUP IS ACTUALLY
OCCURRING AND I GUESS IF
IT'S DON MCGAHN NOT
TESTIFYING THAT'S UP TO DON
MCGAHN.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO LISTEN TO
THE PRESIDENT IF HE DOESN'T
WANT TO.
>> Bret: LESLIE.
>> THAT'S NOT FULL
TRANSPARENCY I WAS AGREEING
WITH YOU UNTIL A COUPLE OF
SENTENCES AGO.
WHEN WE LOOK AT WE NEED TO
HAVE FULL TRANSPARENCY I
AGREE AMERICAN PEOPLE MUST
HAVE FULL TRANSPARENCY
WHETHER IT'S WITH THE
MUELLER REPORT WHICH IS
THREE PRONGED INCLUDING
RUSSIA'S INTERFERENCE WITH
OUR ELECTIONS.
WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT
HAS GONE ON IN THE PAST.
THIS -- BUT THIS IS NOT A
WITCH-HUNT.
AND WHAT BOTHERS ME HERE IS
THE UNDERMINING OF OUR
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS WHO,
YOU KNOW, OUT THERE WITH
THEIR SOURCES AND THEIR
METHODS, THIS COULD BE A
PROBLEM IN THE FUTURE FOR
PEOPLE THAT THEY NEED TO
HAVE SPEAK TO THEM GOING
FORWARD FOR INFORMATION AND
ALSO, THE PERCEPTION BY
MANY, NOT JUST ON THE LEFT
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
PRESIDENT AND PROTECTING THE
PRESIDENT HE TOOK TO HAVE
HIS ALLEGIANCE TO THE CON
STIEWFINGS THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Bret: TO BEN'S POINT.
SO THE COVERUP IS THE
COVERUP OF THE OBSTRUCTIONS
OF JUSTICE.
THE OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
IS DO OBSTRUCT SOMETHING IS
THAT NOT FIND CRIMINAL
INDICTMENT.
RIGHT?
>> YES.
I HAVE TALKED TO LAWYERS WHO
ARE REPUBLICANS WHO SAID,
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE VERY
SURPRISED THAT NOBODY WENT
AFTER WITNESS TAMPERING.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU
HAVE A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
WHO CAME TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THANKFULLY THEY
SAID, LOOK, WE ARE NOT
INTERESTED.
THAT'S NOT A COUP.
THEY WERE DOING THEIR JOB
WITH THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY HAD.
BECAUSE IT'S THREE PRONG AND
ONE OF THE PRONGS OF THAT
INVESTIGATION THAT MULLEN
WAS TASKED WITH WAS TO LOOK
INTO INTERFERENCE BY THE
RUSSIANS.
THIS IS NOT JUST ALL ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT AND ALL ABOUT
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, IT'S
GOING TO BE INTERESTING,
STEVE, WHEN WE SEE AND IT
COULD BE THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORT IN DAYS.
YOU KNOW.
MAYBE WEEKS.
BUT DAYS.
IT WILL BE FASCINATING TO
SEE WHAT'S IN THERE.
>> YES.
TALKS ABOUT UNDERMINING THE
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY SUSPICIOUS IT IS THE
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES
UNDERMINING THE PRESIDENT.
AND THE CANDIDATE.
THAT THEY WERE SUPPORTING
AND I THINK WE SHOULD NOT
UNDERESTIMATE THE FURY OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO
SEE THEIR VOTES FOR DONALD
TRUMP SCORNED ON A DAILY
BASIS BY DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
BASICALLY BLOCKING HIM FROM
GOVERNING WITH THESE ENDLESS
INVESTIGATIONS.
AND THEY WANT EQUAL JUSTICE.
AND I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS THAT
NOW, IT MAY TURN OUT THAT
THESE SUSPICIONS OF A DEEP
STATE COUP AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, IT MAY ALSO BE AS
MUCH OF A CONSPIRACY THEORY
AS THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
STORY TURNED OUT TO BE.
>> Bret: OKAY.
WE WILL FOLLOW ALL ELEMENTS
OF IT, BIG QUESTION IS
WHETHER BOB MULLER IS GOING
TO TESTIFY HERE IS THE
PRESIDENT AND JOHN KARR
NADLER ON THAT.
>>
JERRY NADLER ON
THAT.
>> THEY ASKED HIM TO
TESTIFY.
HE JUST GAVE THEM A 434 PAGE
ROUTER WHICH SAYS NO
COLLUSION.
WHICH LEADS TO ABSOLUTELY NO
OBSTRUCTION.
HE JUST GAVE THAT REPORT.
WHY DOES HE HAVE TO TESTIFY?
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> MUELLER HE, I THINK CAN I
SAY AT THIS POINT HE WANTS
TO TESTIFY IN PRIVACY.
HE ENVISIONS HIMSELF
CORRECTLY AS A MAN OF GREAT
REC TUESDAY AND APOLITICAL
AND HE DOESN'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN ANYTHING THAT
HE MIGHT REGARD AS A
POLITICAL SPECTACLE.
>> Bret: IT IS ALL A
>> AND THE FACT MUELLER IS
DOING THE RIGHT THING.
MUELLER DID PUT OUT HIS
REPORT.
IF MUELLER BELIEVED THAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INDICTED THE PRESIDENT GAVE
HIM EVERY ABILITY TO SAY
THAT SO DID ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR.
THE FACT THAT MUELLER
DECLINED TO ACTUALLY ISSUE
ANY STATEMENT ON WHETHER
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
OCCURRED OR DID NOT THAT WAS
HIS DECISION.
HE COULD HAVE MADE A
RECOMMENDATION.
HE DID NOT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE THE SAME
INFORMATION.
THEY CAN IMPEACH.
THEY ARE NOT MOVING TO DO
SO.
I'M WONDERING WHAT THEY ARE
HOPING TO FIND.
NANCY PELOSI CAME OUT THIS
WEEK AND SAY MORE
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS
WOULDN'T PRODUCE ANY NEW
INFORMATION.
THIS IS POLITICAL GRAND
STANDING TO ME.
>> Bret: IS IT THAT
DEMOCRATS WANT THE
IMPEACHMENT BUT NOT THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS?
THEY WANT THE HEARINGS AND
THE SHOW BUT THEY REALLY
DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN THE
POLITICALLY DANGEROUS WALK
OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> IT IS POLITICALLY
DANGEROUS.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
REPUBLICANS IMPEACHED NEWT BILL
CLINTON.
NEWT GINGRICH RESIGNED.
SPEAKER PELOSI KNOWS.
THIS IN ADDITION WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE POLLS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T WANT
THIS AND THEY DIDN'T WANT IT
THEN BY THE WAY.
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE
APPROXIMATELY 15% OF
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE AND
THE SENATE COMBINED THAT ARE
PUSHING FOR IMPEACHMENT AND
ALTHOUGH IT SEEMS LIKE A
MUCH LARGER NUMBER AND THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE MORE SPLIT,
THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
BUT, WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO BY HAVING MUELLER SIT
THERE IS ASK QUESTIONS SUCH
AS SO WHY DIDN'T YOU PUSH
FOR OBSTRUCTION?
WHAT SPECIFICALLY WERE YOUR
CONCERNS?
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT ONE AREA.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
10-PLUS AREAS WHERE HE WAS
QUESTIONING BUT HE DID LEAVE
THAT UP TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S WRONG
WITH THEIR OVERSIGHT
CONSTITUTIONALLY TO ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS SO THEY ARE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS THEY
HAVE EVERY SINGLE I DOTTED
AND T CROSSED.
>> Bret: REPUBLICANS WOULD
BE ASKING WHY DIDN'T YOU
LOOK AT WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
DID AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PROCESS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Bret: WHY DIDN'T YOU LOOK
AT THE ORIGINAL START OF THE
INVESTIGATION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHICH IS WHY I WOULD THINK
THAT REPUBLICANS WOULD BE,
YOU KNOW, WALKING HAND IN
HAND IF YOU WILL WITH
DEMOCRATS SAYING WE WANT HIM
TO SIT DOWN AS WELL BECAUSE
WE HAVE QUESTIONS WE WANT
ANSWERED.
>> Bret: THIS WITH PRESIDENT
AND NANCY PELOSI.
NOW HAVE YOU TWEETED VIDEOS
AND BACK AND FORTH ABOUT
SOMEBODY HAS GOT TO CHECK
WHETHER THERE IS
INTERVENTION NEEDED.
WHAT DO WE TAKE FROM THIS?
>> I THINK MOST PEOPLE LOOK
AT THAT IN JUST DESPAIR AND
THINK THIS WHOLE THING IS
PANTOMIME.
IF YOU LOOK AT AGNAT MY OF
WHAT HAPPENED THIS WEEK VERY
EVIDENT NANCY PELOSI
INSULTED THE PRESIDENT USING
ALL THESE ACCUSATIONS OF A
WATERGATE STYLE COVERUP
BEFORE AN IMPORTANT MEETING
THAT THEY CLAIMED THEY WERE
IN FAVOR OF.
I THINK SHE IS A COMPLETELY
DISINGENUOUS CHART TAP OVER.
THIS REDICK LUST THEY ARE
TRYING TO PRETEND THEY ARE
DOING ANYTHING OTHER THAN
TRYING TO BLOCK THIS
PRESIDENT FROM ACHIEVING
ANYTHING AT ALL.
>> Bret: I JUST HAVE -- JUST
YOUR FACE TOUGH RESPOND.
>> OKAY.
FIRST OF ALL, MY INSIDERS ON
THE LEFT TALKING TO ME, ONE
OF THEM, THERE WASN'T A PLAN
TO HAVE TWO RUSHED MEETINGS,
YOU KNOW, TO TALK ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT UNTIL THE
PRESIDENT SAID MCGAHN CAN'T
TESTIFY, UP TO HIM.
HE SAID I'M NOT GOING TO
TESTIFY AND THEY WERE
PANICKING THAT HAPPENED TO
BE BEFORE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
MEETING.
YES, WE CAN BE CLEVER THAT
WASN'T LIKE A CLEVER COUP IF
YOU WILL.
WE SEE PEOPLE, POLITICIANS
LEFT AND RIGHT, THE
PRESIDENT INCLUDED INSULT
EACH OTHER ALL THE TIME.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE NEED TO HAVE A THICKER
SKIN.
I'M SORRY.
SHE SAID WHAT SHE FELT AND
SENTIMENTS OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE NOT ONLY IN THE PARTY
BUT THAT PUT HER IN THE
POSITION TO BE SPEAKER.
>> Bret: CAN THIS PRESIDENT
WITH THIS CONGRESS GET
ANYTHING DONE BEFORE THE